okay so i'm going to show you three
definitions a lot of folks get their
impressions by what you see on TV here's
what a president of the u.s. a
fictitious president of the u.s. booked
a very widely seen one on the west wing
TV shows that happened to see this
episode actually a number of years ago
he was talked about its energy policy he
said clean coal has internal pollsters
came up with because the polls higher
than regular coal what we want our real
cleaner burning fuels and alternative
energy if you go to the current
president's website and look at his
energy strategy something called all the
above what president obama talks about
clean coal doesn't actually define it
but it talks about it as being part of a
strategy to take control of our energy
future invested substantially in
cost-effective carbon capture and
sequestration and finally if you go to
an industrial website good call the
American Coalition for Clean Coal
electricity they actually do have a
definition they define it as
technologies that improve the
environmental performance of coal based
electricity plants but they don't really
say how much improvement and they list a
number of options some of which make
very small improvements some of which
make larger improvement so how clean is
clean what we try to do here Carnegie
Mellon is we frame these questions into
things that are suitable for looking at
through a research program and and so
among the questions we try to ask and
answer are things like what options
actually are available to reduce
environmental emissions and impacts of
coal-fired power plants especially these
days greenhouse gases like co2 carbon
dioxide how weldon different options
work how effective
what do they cost and what are some of
those trade-offs we also try to look and
this is where technology innovation in a
serious way comes in what's the outlook
for new improved technologies that have
lower costs or better performance and
from a policy perspective what does one
need to do how can we spur the
technology innovations in fact that are
needed to do a better and more
cost-effective job and finally we look
at we use the technical analysis to look
at issues of what policies regulations
and incentives if any in fact are needed
to achieve these lower emissions so what
comes out of this research program a
couple of things some one of our
research products in this particular
domain are tools and we and lots of
other people can use to actually
evaluate clean coal technologies
whatever it wants to mean in their
particular context so for example we've
developed over years a computer tool
called I ECM integrated environmental
control model that's now being used
actually by several thousand people
around the world many of them students
many of the folks in industry many
regulators to ask and answer questions
about performance additions costs and
uncertainties in the context of the
issues that they are addressing another
set of products are various studies that
we put out to in fact address key policy
issues here a couple of examples the
book looks much better in person this
just came out what a couple of weeks ago
Granger Granger and a couple of by the
dozen of us both here at Carnegie Mellon
and elsewhere around the country I
worked for a couple of years looking at
legal and regulatory issues concerning a
technology called carbon capture and
storage or sequestration looking at what
would actually have to do to make this
technology viable and I've been involved
in in various studies looking at how we
can raise money for long
still projects just to see if the thing
works and if it's really is safe and
effective as advertised so I put on this
slide a couple of what i think are key
highlights that come out of the research
and trying to redress these these
questions i think what are your key
findings is that in fact there is
technology available today that can
reduce environmental impacts of
coal-based power plants by varying
degrees there are a series of devices
emission control systems I've called
them here that can reduce emissions of
water pollutants and air pollutants
quite effectively 92 almost a hundred
percent depending on which pollutant
we're talking about there are other
technologies of these are some of things
alluded to in the industrial website
that can also make some improvements
more on the order of ten to thirty
percent simply by building power plants
that have higher efficiency using a lot
of that way steam raising the
temperatures and using other
technologies that Granger mentioned
earlier and we also so basically if we
ask what's what's standing in the way of
getting as clean as possible right now
large-scale demonstrations of this
technology called carbon capture and
storage or sequestration basically
capturing carbon from from coal-fired
power plants and storing it sequestering
at geologically we need to basically
know that this really does work at large
scale that we can address not only
technical issues but issues of public
acceptance and safety and we are in
desperate need of these kinds of things
just to know whether that really is an
option we also need to reduce the cost
of that and finally widespread
deployment of these technologies as well
as many others really makes no sense
than there's not going to have an absent
sufficiently strong set of energy
Environmental Policy drivers that are
lacking at this time so a second set of
research questions essentially then is
given that we're currently relying very
heavily on fossil fuels about seventy
percent of electricity and eighty-five
percent of all of our energy comes from
fossil fuels what really is the
potential realistically of clean coal
technologies moving toward this notion
of a sustainable low-carbon energy
system basically how do you get there
from here this is one of the critical
set of issues that this institute will
be dealing with because choices that you
make and paths that you take are often
not reversible and answers to that
question will depend on thoughtful of
technical and policy analysis so how do
you get some insights about that most of
the way that's done is through a variety
of energy modeling and forecasting
methods and studies what I've shown here
are results from five different energy
models that were looking at future
scenarios for us energy development
there are others that look at this
globally and different models give you
different answers there's no single
answer to how do you get there from here
but what all of these efforts and our
best analysis to date suggests is that
coal with carbon capture and storage if
in fact you're looking for serious
reductions in carbon emissions and
dealing with the reality of just how
much fossil energy is in use today not
only here but places like China and
India this technology of carbon capture
and storage is one of the critical
components of a cost effective strategy
to get to that sustainable future it's
not the only strategy but he means lots
of other things that needed but the bet
is always critical the other thing
that's relatively new is it's not just
about coal anymore so I'd like to coin a
term here and it says clean gas
technologies particularly if we start
taking somewhat gene
shale gas and burning that in power
plants gas ain't so clean as it's often
thought to be and they're certainly not
carbon free and so just in terms of
carbon emissions this notion of carbon
capture and storage on natural gas-fired
power plants which are growing in
popularity is also something that will
be needed in this transition to a
sustainable energy future so I've tried
to put this together into this little
file cartoon that suggests that in fact
clean coal as well as clean gas
technologies potentially if we choose to
go down the policy right of actually
getting serious about reducing carbon
emissions and heading toward a
sustainable these in fact could be
actually didn't work could be part of a
FF of a future evolution of our energy
systems thanks very much
you